Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host David Flanagan.
Today we're taking a look at Dagger dot
I o. Dagger is a tool for building
CICD
pipelines. Go check out Dagger.i0
to learn more and of course keep watching
this video. I'm going to show you how
to use Dagger in a model repository context
with secrets,
composable builds that you can run anywhere
including local host. As we see here on
the Dagger website,
you can run your Dagger pipelines anywhere.
Why?
Well, because they're just orchestrated containers.
So as long as you can run a
container on your local machine,
in GitHub actions, CircleCI or even in production
or on a Kubernetes cluster,
you can run your Dagger pipelines.
One of the main selling points or what
makes Dagger unique
is that Dagger pipelines don't require you to
write any YAML. You can define your Dagger
pipelines as code. Today, we will be using
Go, but you can also use Python,
JavaScript,
TypeScript
and realistically
any programming language. While these are the main
ones supported by Dagger, as we can see
on the homepage here, GraphQL
is what makes all of this work. So
provided you can take a GraphQL schema, you
could probably generate some sort of SDK or
you could just write GraphQL and use your
favorite programming language to execute it. That's up
to you and maybe something we'll play around
with on another video. But today, we're gonna
focus on Go, where I'm gonna show you
how to build your classic three tier application.
The back end service written in Go, the
front end service running in JavaScript,
a database which could be either SQLite or
Postgres and
consumption of secrets.
So let's dive in. Alright.
So before we go into the code, before
I show you Dagger, let's see what our
local dev experience looks like without Dagger. That
is pretty good and local dev experiences usually
are.
However, they're not repeatable and other machines and
other infrastructure and especially not in production. So
I can go into the back end surface
where I can do go run main. Go.
That's a pretty hard dev experience to be.
You know, they're using native tooling on a
native machine and go makes it pretty easy.
We can then jump down here where we
do a curl to local host on eighty
eighty
or we can have the ping endpoint and
we get pong back.
This API also has an ask endpoint where
we can provide
a post request with curl that means just
providing a JSON body or anybody
where we can provide a JSON request
where we pass in
a question. The question could be
translate
hello
from English
to German
and hit return. Now we get an error
and that's because we need a secret value.
However, I've got that covered.
Inside my top level directory,
I have an ENVRC.
Inside of this, I have the OpenAI token.
However, I have it set to this funny
looking string.
This funny looking string is a one password
secret reference.
Now I can use this here because I
have one password on my machine. Whatever your
secrets management is, use that. One password is
a good choice. You can run the operator
and production and still consume secrets in the
exact same way.
Other notable options are Doppler from doppler.com.
So that's up to you.
Locally,
I can do op run,
go run main,
where it will pop up on my watch
and approve the request. And if I run
our command again,
we get the answer. Hello and dosh is
hello. So now we have a pretty good
dev experience.
We can now go into our front end
application
where we do a PMPM
run dev.
I can pop this open in my browser
where I get my wonderful developer focused UI,
which just means black text on a white
background,
where I can ask questions of Dagger AI.
So let's see if we can translate
hello
to Polish.
And voila.
I'm gonna trust ChatGPT.
So that's pretty good. But we're having to
manage the back end, run the front end,
and we're consuming secrets in a pretty good
way, but still a little bit too much
work.
There's one other thing we haven't done yet
and that is run our test suite. So
we're gonna come out of the front end
where we go into build test. Here, I
have a test dot huddl file. If you're
not familiar with huddle, go to huddle dot
dev. That is h u r l dot
dev. Gives you a text based format to
describe HTTP requests where you can build assertions
against their response. Here, I do a get
on back end eighty eighty ping where I
expect a 200.
I also do a post to back end
eighty eighty ask, sending in my JSON payload
with a question and asserting that I get
the German word for hello back end response.
We can now do hurl, test dot hurl
and we see that it fails because we
need to speak to something called back end.
Now I could use local host here but
that's not gonna work repeatably in other machines
and other environments.
So for this, I have created a just
target where we can run just test and
our tests pass.
If we take a look at our just
fail, we're using a nifty feature of hurl
where we can pass dash dash connect to
where we swap out the back end eighty
eighty tuple for local host eighty eighty tuple.
This is a decent developer environment at the
moment. We have a just failed to handle
the edge case where we can run the
tests and where there could be a container
based environment. But we wanna pull more automation
into this. We want to be able to
run it anywhere and we wanna be able
to expand on this. If you started down
a service oriented architecture or you're using a
mono repository, it doesn't stop at three services
or two services. It's potentially going to grow
and using composition
of our CICD system, being able to reference
other modules and actions
and chain them together
is gonna be paramount to your success. So
let's see how we can take this three
tier application,
automate it with Dagger with a pipeline we
can run anywhere that's extensible,
cacheable and performant.
So let's take a look at some code.
Let's go through the back end first. This
is a very simple Go application using the
Gen web framework.
As you can see here, we rely on
an environment variable called open ai underscore token.
This is how we provide that secret to
the back end to speak to the chat
GPT service. There's one other environment detail that
is required for this application to work.
When it's submitted, it's going to use an
in memory SQLite database.
Great for dev,
but doesn't resemble production. So we wanna be
able to provide this database URI with the
same production environment that we use when we
run our CI system.
For today's example, we're going to use Postgres.
I'm also a big believer
that when you write code, the code that
you use to orchestrate it, manage it, build
it and run it should live right next
to it. We shouldn't be shipping this stuff
away to another repository or another directory.
It just doesn't make sense. So you'll see
here, I have a build directory with a
build dot go. This contains the Dagger code
and function that are specific
to this individual service.
As you'll see here, we pull in the
Dagger API or the Dagger SDK
and we expose two functions. One called build
container image, which is consumed by the export
container image. If you've been writing code for
one year, five years, ten years, twenty years,
or longer,
you have accumulated
experience.
You've learned how to write more code in
a better fashion. Why do we throw this
away when it comes to CICD
when we just write YAML? Let's take all
of that experience
and build composable,
extensible, maintainable build pipelines. Now this is a
contrived example right now. I'm consuming a function
from another function,
but still is just the tip of the
iceberg. So our export container function
calls build and then publishes it to GHCR
and that's it.
Our build function
because this is just Go code can use
just Go code.
We can just use format dot print to
stick something into the console or logs.
It's just that simple. Now because this is
a mono repository,
you're gonna see some funny little bits of
lines of code here where I use runtime
caller to get the current directory of this
specific source file
so that I can pluck out small parts
of the mono repository to consume them in
other parts of the system. I'm gonna skip
over it for now but if you want
to learn more, ask questions or just find
the code, the links are in the show
notes below. Once we have the source directory
for this individual service, we can use the
Dagger client to get a container.
We're gonna start with Golang latest
where we mount our source directory to slash
source.
We set the working directory to slash source
and look, we run a go build and
that's it. Now this could be done with
a Dockerfile. Sure. And can Dagger use a
Dockerfile? Yes, it can. However, when we do
it as code, it just becomes a little
bit more maintainable and composable.
We can reuse these step definitions.
I can actually stop here,
assign this to a variable like build output
and then do something else with it multiple
times.
Or maybe I run go build here for
one architecture but then run it again for
a different.
I'm not gonna cover multi architecture right now
because Dagger cover that really well in the
documentation.
So remember, dagger.io.
Check out the docs, check out the cookbooks
and the guides.
Now, we all know that multistage builds are
how we should be shipping things to production.
We don't want to ship the entire Golang
tool chain to a production image. So let's
get a new container from Ubuntu 22
where we grab a file from the previous
build. You can see here we're seeing web
fail store to slash entry point and what
we're gonna store there? Well, it's the output
or the fail output from another build, notably
our build output
where the fail is slash source slash back
end which is the fail we built. We
can then set the entry point and wipe
out the default args. This is now an
image that we can publish
as we do with the export container image
function.
Voila.
There's no other Dagger code here other than
these two helper functions next to the back
end. That's just for today's example and not
necessarily something you would do in a real
application,
but we'll cover that in another video. So
for today's example,
all of the code or the build pipeline
that we're going to work with lives inside
the build directory.
If we open our test package,
we have a main dot go. This just
means that I can run main dot go
here to test the service oriented architecture, which
I'm pushing with that definition. This three tier
application
with a single endpoint.
Consider this like an acceptance test. Okay. So
the first thing we have in here is
our main function. This just allows us to
run go run on this file and run
the entire test harness.
That is just handing off to a build
function
which creates a Dagger client.
Now we know that our back end service
has a few inputs that are required for
it to run successfully.
Notably, it needs an OpenAI token so that
it can speak to the chat GPT API.
Here we have a dev tool dot get
secret.
This is a helper function that I provide
in a dev tool library
that can be used anywhere in their Dagger
pipelines.
It takes a secret reference which is a
string and returns a string or an error.
The error being if the secret reference could
not be resolved.
It's important to note that we do not
pass the Dagger client into this function. Why
is that important? I'll get to in just
a moment. So let's pop in and take
a look at get secret.
It takes the string and returns a string.
We can see that it's actually just executing
a command on my host. That's why it's
important that there's no Dagger client. Why is
that even more important when it refers to
secrets?
Because we execute this command on the host
as me. I am ambiently authenticated as me
to speak to one password.
In fact, when the op read hits my
host, you've seen that it popped up on
my watch for me to approve. It's important
that this is not happening in a container
context
because the minute it does, we have that
potential
that our container or CI cache could have
sensitive information
and we want to minimize that risk whenever
possible.
So our get secret speaks to one password
on the host, returns a string. So of
course, once we have this string here and
assuming there's no error,
the first thing we want to do is
to sanitize this in a way that we
can use it in our container context without
it being leaked into the build cache or
even out in the logs. So you'll see
here that we call client a Dagger client
dot set secret where we say that we
want to name the secret OpenAI token
and the value is our value from one
password. This now means that we have enough
guarantees
that this will not end up in our
logs and we'll do a demo to prove
that before the end of this video. Next,
we call dev tool dot get database.
This is a function that is going to
return our production like configured postgres instance so
that we're not using SQLite in our test
harness.
Again, trying to minimize the variance between production
and test. That get database looks like this.
This does take a Dagger client,
so we know there's a container involved
and in fact we get a container,
we start with Postgres 15 as a base,
we set the environment variables that we know
need to exist in order for this container
to run healthily, which is the user, the
password and a database name and because we're
going to use this in our Dagger context,
we're just gonna say that this exposes port
five four three two so that when we
run this as a dependent service,
the networking will work. Now it's important to
know that this is code. Right? Dagger pipelines
are code which means we can do code
like things. It may be
that you don't always want Postgres 15.
It may be that you don't always want
to just support Postgres. Perhaps as an organization,
you're starting to test MySQL,
CockroachDB,
MongoDB,
your toolchain, you decide. But you still want
to provide helpers that allow people to test
their applications with good velocity. So
obviously,
the simple approach would be just to say,
you know, get 14
and then we have a video. Right? But
there's a lot of shared code between this
and again,
because we're using code for our pipelines, we
can do code like things. So instead of
just duplicating the code, why don't we do
struct config DB
version
is string. Now I could have called that
post credit version and I was about to,
but we could prepare for the future. We
may support multiple drivers at one point. We
can then say that this 14 is actually
get database with a config where
we have a config. That now means that
this Postgres
can become a formatted string
like so. And we're formatting this with config
dot db version
and then we save that to resolve the
format import. Now we still have a lot
of duplication and again, you've got experience of
writing code, I've got experience with writing code.
We have patterns that we use for composition.
We have patterns that we use for maintainable
code.
Those all apply to your Dagger pipelines.
But we still have a lot of duplication.
So what we can actually do is remove
that and just say that actually,
we're just going to call get database of
config with a default config where that database
version is 15. Now this is backwards compatible,
it's maintainable,
and it's extensible. We can now modify and
expand our config, making sure the default case
is always what was the default case, but
have a function that can return whatever we
need. And that is pretty cool. So now
that we have our database, we can start
to build up the services that we need
to run our test harness. You can see
here that we're pulling on something called backend
builder dot build container image. And if you
remember looking at the Dagger code for each
service,
the backend service, it had a function called
build container image, which we're now using. We're
then enriching it with a database URI
and we're setting this to postgres postgres postgres
database five four three two postgres.
We're just setting up based on the information
that we have from here.
Now this could get smarter yet. Again, it's
code and you can do code like things.
What if the return type here
was actually a database
credentials
which had a host, a username,
a password
and a port. We can now start to
consume all of these details
here
and remove the hard coded strings. Now I'm
not gonna do all of this today,
but hopefully I'm showing you that again, Dagger,
code,
maintainability,
extensibility and composability
all give you a lot of power to
treat your Dagger pipelines
like real software projects, improve them, maintain them
and make them faster. Once we've configured the
database UI, we pass in our OpenAI token.
Now because this is a secret, we're passing
this in as web secret variable.
Why are we doing this? Because we never
want this to leak. I'm feeling bold enough
that I'm gonna go to our back end
service and paste in a printf.
The prints are token to the log output.
Now because we mount this end to the
container as a secret reference,
it should be redacted
in the log output.
We then say that the port is eighty
eighty and we expose this port to be
consumed by the test harness container
and of course our backend has a dependent
service. So we're going to do web service
binding under the DNS host name database to
the database container.
We're just connecting these two together so that
our back end can make requests over the
DNS name database to the Postgres instance. And
then we set a web exec as empty
which just means trigger that entry point that
we configured
production image. Now I am using a little
bit of runtime caller just to get again
a specific subset of our mono repository.
In this case,
I'm grabbing the test dot hull directory or
the directory that contains the test dot hull
and I'm mounting that into a container which
is using the hull three point o image.
This has a back end, this has a
dependent service too. The hull test suite needs
to be able to speak to the back
end over the DNS name backend.
We've seen this in the hull file itself
and the workaround and the just file for
local execution.
We mount the directory,
we set the entry point and we pass
exec which is the command in the Dockerfile
or the arguments to the entry point. Now
because of these can pass or fail, we
grab the exit code
and we grab standard error. I could grab
standard error but I don't need it in
this particular instance. As the exit code is
not zero, this means that a failure happened,
failure occurred. So let's print out a red
goblin or devil, whatever that is. With test
fails, we'll print the exit code and we'll
print the error output.
And if things worked successfully,
green tick and passed.
So we're going to run this again.
What we expect to see is a redacted
secret inside of our log output and our
test passing
using two dependent services powered by Dagger. Now
because this is Go code,
I can and we will in a moment
run the test main dot go as a
straight up file. However,
only feedback you're going to get from Dagger
is the format dot print lines that you
do unless you configure the debug
on the Dagger connection.
However, there's an experimental UI
which you may remember as set inside the
ENVRC.
To use that experimental UI, we can do
Dagger run, go run
build
test
main. When I run this, we're going to
see the complete graph of all the steps
that Dagger is going to run
and whether they're successful,
whether they're in progress or whether they have
failed.
So the UI should pop up and right
away because one of the first things that
we do is a host call
to get my password.
We can actually see the only step in
the DAG right now is the go run.
There are no container executions at all. Let's
approve that
and now we're pulling Golang latest and Postgres.
A lot of this will be cash because
I've run this demo many many times. However,
we did make a modification to the go
binary which may trigger the build. So we're
gonna give that just a few seconds to
finish. Okay. So our test suite has now
finished. If we go to the very top,
we'll see that the build has passed. But
what we're interested in seeing is a redacted
secret and the dependent service output.
So let's scroll down to the dependent service
where we have the entry point here.
And as you'll see, we have our output
of API token is here where it's just
replaced with three stars. Sweet.
Now the Dagger UI is great, you can
use that as much as you want. It's
great for debugging observability
into what's actually happening now with part of
the pipeline. But of course, because this is
all just go code,
we can also just do Go run build
test where build test is the module name
of where my test runner is and the
main dot go.
I run this like this. When it finishes,
all we're going to see is any print
statements that I have such as build a
container image And the last print statement will
either be test pass or test fail.
Enter test pass.
Of course, never trust a test suite that
passes twice in a row, especially mine. Let's
come on to our test dot huddle. Now
I'm not going to change any Go code
or cache within the build system should still
be pretty good. Meaning even if I change
the test suite, it should run against the
cached and built artifacts.
Meaning, it should be really fast.
So
I'm pretty sure ChatGPT is not going to
see Rawkode in response to our question.
So let's run this one more time and
see the tests fail.
And at nine seconds as opposed to over
a minute, we see
that we do not get Rawkode
as part of our response.
Nice.
So that's it for this video. Hopefully, you
have a good taste for the things you
can do with Dagger now. The key takeaways
are one, Dagger is awesome. You can write
complete CICD pipelines and whatever programming language you
want. Taking advantage of all the years of
experience you have of writing code and applying
them to your build system. We can pull
in secrets. We can have dependent services.
We can have a CI system that is
truly composable.
And that is worth its weight in gold.
So go check out Dagger now. Remember to
check out dagger.i0
for all the latest news and announcements as
well as some great documentation.
I'll see you next time. Have a great
day.